all right it is a new era for hatred
mail we have all sorts of new hatred
mail introductions that we will be
debuting
including this one today because it's
time to make
america hate again
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom all right we've got
a double dose of hatred mail today as
you know the anti-semitism
has exploded after the election of
donald trump as president-elect as i
told you last week
it continues the first of two here we
talked about this one in particular
it's much more compelling when read
professionally that is
episode one of two for today of hatred
mail let's take a listen
you are a filthy jew [ __ ] you've made
russia the boogeyman for no reason
typical jew tactic all the elites are
left-wing
godless jews right hey dumb commie jew
you're not america you are a despicable
leftist leech
that hates this country and we hate you
back
you've been trumped jew [ __ ]
the jew has been defeated yeah so okay
that was actually the new one and then
we will go
also because we are doing a double dose
of post-trump hate
this is the the specific one that i
discussed in more detail earlier this
week
jew media failed you're nothing but an
inbred [ __ ] gas chamber rat pacman
no one listened to this [ __ ] jew
media this election
and no one ever will again everyone is
now aware of you
kykes promoting white genocide you are
finished jew boy enjoy your new
president yeah so we're going to be
talking more about this there has been a
significant uptick in this type of thing
believe me i am i am
not the only person targeted by this
type of post-trump rhetoric
we're going to get more into the data
next what i can say in the short run
about this is
uh corporate media failed us we cannot
allow this type of thing and the steve
bannon's and all of that to be
normalized in any way
and the best ways to support independent
media which you can do with
davidpakman.com membership
coupon code hatred40 patriot 40 turn
hatred mail into something positive
also get your calendars at
davidpakman.com
calendar 17.